okay
hi welcome
thank you
so how many of you have been to
Philippe's excellent talk just before
this one yeah excellent so we can leave
[Laughter]
it almost feels a little bit pointless
now to talk about all of this
that's why I I decided I'm you know like
basically the talk has two parts one is
more like the how and um sorry the why
and the tech the the historical
perspective so to speak I'm gonna like
try to get through this a little bit
quicker because we are at a security
conference I think you all believe me
that Crossfire request forgery does
exist yeah which not not everyone does
but
and and then we're going to focus more
on the BFF part and uh you know like how
we build it uh how you can build it uh
and and some things we learned along the
way I guess
okay so my name is Dominic I do security
for a living
and I've built a couple of uh projects
like identity server and also this BFF
library that we are that we build based
on you know Lessons Learned
um from this talk and and many many
other things
um oh yeah and the you can reach me here
and the slides are here on speaker deck
so if you want to have the slides
afterwards just feel free to download
them
good so as I said
um I want to first look a little bit at
history where we are yeah um or where we
are coming from and then and then
basically looking uh spending more time
with the this new uh new ish actually uh
idea of a BFF which is not best friends
forever as you probably know it's uh
it's a uh back end for front end yeah so
um basically you know um if you've been
doing that stuff for long enough like
like me right I mean I have the gray
hair to prove it
um you've seen multiple waves of
guidance how to secure front-end
applications right it's it's a bit like
a pendulum yeah that's the way I see
this yeah first we were swinging totally
towards uh secure everything with
cookies right and then cookies we had
some problems with that and we were
swinging more like secure everything
with tokens yeah and now as often the
truth I guess is somewhere in the middle
which brings us then to the back end for
a front-end pattern which kind of tries
to separate the concerns between the UI
and the security Parts okay
so yeah so let's go quickly over this
um one thing
um I I've got called out recently by on
Hacker News saying like ah this guy
doesn't know anything about spas and
JavaScript why would we listen to him
yeah his security guidance doesn't apply
to us yeah
um I wrote this blog post with the title
Spas are dead
which is of course perfect click bait
yeah
um but I said in the very first sentence
yeah that's a joke people didn't read
that far I think
um
so whenever I talk about spas or
browser-based applications or you know
Blazer awesome or whatever you want to
call it
it's from my point of view which is
typically business applications okay so
we have a browser-based application
running in the browser I very often deal
with authentication typically via openly
connect for you know single sign-on
purposes for Federation software as a
service you know all of these scenarios
and I pretty often deal with then you
have to call apis from that front end
and very often oauth is somewhere used
in that architecture now so that's kind
of like the world I'm living in and I
totally acknowledge that there might be
spars out there that don't have this
architecture and maybe for these bars
the talk doesn't apply who knows I don't
know them yeah
so
um
as I said when I started writing web
applications right that was like uh
classic ASP for example Microsoft active
server Pages you know afterwards asp.net
yeah and pretty much everything was
what the cool kids today call server
side rendered applications
right it's a new invention yeah it means
that that the UI is coming from the
server
um and you know pretty much we use the
postback model right you rendered a page
there was a form you click a button you
submit back to the server and the cookie
right was authenticating that postback
back to the server right and then
Microsoft or at some point the the HX
term got coined right and Microsoft does
anyone remember the HX control toolkit
for for asp.net Brilliant Invention
right you just slapped something on no
more flickering in the browser which was
the goal we wanted to achieve right it
was horrible
technically and again it it used this
thing called you know HX calls under the
covers to to avoid the postback but it
was still using cookies of course to to
secure the whole thing right
um and then at some point in
cross-centric respiratory was discovered
right
um which is exactly attacking this that
the browser is just sending the cookie
on your behalf automatically there's
nothing you have to do right and I think
the very first or the very first known
to me big web application that was uh
attacked using sea serve was Amazon
right you you remember the one click buy
button where you had like a link on the
web page and you clicked the link and
you bought a book
and it was using basically the fact that
you are logged into Amazon the cookie
travels along you click the link you buy
the book now guess what if I put up a
blog post about my book and I put like
an image tag on that and put the image
source to that one click buy button
you're not only reading my blog post
you're also buying my book
right and that was basically
um crosstalk request forgery and the way
it worked is basically you know you open
a tab in your browser you go to your
application you log in the browser sends
you an authentication cookie
and you're good to go right and now
imagine you're opening another tab in
the browser you're going to evil.com
whatever right
um and then evil.com starts making HTTP
calls to the application backend yeah
calling something and by and basically
because the browser has an
authentication cookie for the
server-side app it's going to send along
that authentication cookie here as well
right
um that doesn't even need Ajax right you
could just do four on postbacks or you
know things like that yeah
um so that's cross request forgery
normally I would I would do a demo for
that as I said I believe you that you
believe me yeah
um
so that was a problem because people
started securing their api-ish endpoints
using cookies yeah and when we
discovered this it it became possible to
call these API endpoints from a from a
third party right from from a from
across side that's where the name comes
from yeah
um and for everyone who did MVC in their
life they know there is a countermeasure
for that right it's called anti-fortery
tokens yeah and the way nd43 tokens
worked is is that when you're rendering
down a form yeah they are setting an
md43 cookie and they are embedding an
anti-forgery token into the form field
right
um which is like an application
generated secret if you like
um and when you're posting back the form
uh both values post back the cookie and
the hidden field you had a server-side
filter running here that looked at both
values if they were fine okay good we'll
be good to go okay pretty much every MVC
developer in the world knows this right
because it was part of all the templates
that Microsoft put out there
what about web apis
did you secure them in the same way
well in theory yes right um the the
solution could have been right you're
rendering down the form
um and then when you're making making
the HX callback you're sending the
cookie and you are reading the value of
that field here and you're putting it on
a header and sending back to the server
how many of you did that
a couple right
but much less than everybody just said
like yeah NBC right why because
Microsoft was never including this in
the templates right many people didn't
know about this that that you have to do
this yeah
um and I did a lot of code reviews in my
life where I found exactly that all the
NBC endpoints were perfectly secured but
the API endpoints were just open to
across that request forgery ma'am so
um this was a problem right and um this
is now getting us closer to our story
here is um
the ietf saw that problem too right and
the IIT I said okay you know what we're
working on this overall spec
um how about
we try to start off the browser
problem as well and see since at this at
this moment in time it all boiled down
to that the cookies are the problems
here so why don't we replace the cookies
with tokens
right tokens have this nice properties
that they are not sent automatically by
the browser you have to explicitly send
them which means crosstalk request
forgery is not the issue here yeah
um also people like the idea that with
tokens you could come you could now send
stuff cross origin or cross side which
you couldn't do
um with cookies so
there's actually when when you go back
to the overall archive every single
email that they ever wrote about the
overall spec is archived yeah and when
you go back to 2000 I don't know nine or
something someone said like we should
think about overall for browser-based
applications and the immediate response
was why would you ever build an
application using JavaScript
so
so they didn't consider this in in the
first place but there were some people
saying yeah this is going to be a thing
yeah believe me and um so they started
thinking about this and uh By the time
um
um you know like the the code flow in
oauth did exist before but the code for
didn't work because you could not do
cross-origin HX calls in JavaScript and
that would be the you know the
prerequisite for getting the back
Channel token so they came up with this
other thing called implicit flows yeah
and at the implicit flow which kind of
is an evil hack right uh and what the
implicit flow try to solve is doing
um
cross-origin requests and the the
solution for that was we're gonna
basically make the whole or thing work
with redirects only yeah like top level
redirects and we're gonna ship our
tokens over urls okay so just you know
I'm sorry but I have flows on my slide
just to recap that right that's how
implicit flow worked you made a token
request to the server the server send
you back the access token on the URL and
then you would store the access token in
inside of your browser right and then
you would use it
now
is that good from a security point of
view
I mean to make it short no
um
transmission of tokens over URLs is is
leaky
as it can get okay these URLs are ending
up in log files in browser histories in
Reverse proxies in referral headers
right and you could link them with your
own problems and and so on so there were
lots of ways how you could
um leak those tokens right and since
there are better tokens for all of you
that know you know came to my talk
yesterday they are better tokens once
you have the token you can use it ma'am
um
so they they did the first thing they
try to fix now and um fast forwarding to
today is they deprecated this flow
altogether because they thought okay the
only reason we invented this flow was
because certain things did not exist
back then for example cross origin uh
you know HX calls for example yeah so
they said okay now we have that course
right now we have that we don't need it
anymore and we can make this much better
right so they said okay and from now on
applications will use the code flow the
browser-based applications which in a
nutshell looks like this right you're
first opening the front Channel doing
all of your UI stuff and then you're
getting the actual access token over a
back Channel yeah like an HX call
basically which means it does not need
to be
transmitted anymore over
the URL
okay so they solved one problem but
you still have to store that token and
manage it in inside the browser which is
the other half of the equation which you
know Philip just explained in great
detail is not secure
because we have the problem of
cross-site scripting and once you have
cross-eyed scripting or other similar
things you can either exfiltrate that
token or reuse some other state in the
front and to to get your own tokens
right so
that's the main problem here token
storage is an unsolved problem in
browsers
there is no Secure Storage in the
browser right every storage mechanism by
Design is accessible from JavaScript and
whatever is accessible from JavaScript
is accessible from malicious JavaScript
injected into your code right
um
and again I'm feeling like I'm repeating
Philips
story here it is on top of the ovest top
10 for the last
15 years or 10 years or whatever right
some sort of injection attacks I'm
pretty cool there's some research from
Google showing that Specter attacks you
know the thing where you can start you
know expect there was this this attack
against servers where you could start
reading RAM on the server that they also
work in browsers right so you could
potentially with with valid JavaScript
yeah start poking around in the in the
ram of the browser process for example
yeah so again the browser is not a great
place to store tokens yeah that's why
back then in the implicit flow they they
thought like yeah okay this is going to
be a problem that's why they did not
allow refresh tokens in the first place
right because refresh tokens if you if
you leak an access token that's bad if
you leak a refresh token that's even
worse because that allows the attacker
to get new access tokens right so
um let me show you that so that's
um a JavaScript library that we worked
on many years ago and basically this is
exactly doing what the overall spec was
suggesting you're driving the complete
open by the connect and overflow from
the browser with code flow Pixi all the
bells and whistles okay
um so when I run this
right I'm at the same design school as a
Philip
um you know you log in
you're getting your login UI
all of the old magic is happening bam
tokens in the browser
right and now the API can start as
already the client can start calling
calling apis of course these tokens need
to be stored somewhere right in in this
case
it is a
where is it
word
where are my tokens data they used to be
in in session storage I know that's
weird let's restart
log in
hmm huh
it doesn't matter you get my point yeah
um I I'm not sure why this is not
working this worked like an hour ago
um but you know they are somewhere in
the browser okay in memory in session
storage in local storage indexeddb
whatever and when you're getting
um
uh um and an injection attack of
thoughts you can steal that token okay
so as I said and that's why originally
um the implicit flow disallowed refresh
tokens because to mitigate that risk but
refresh tokens are a way of of doing
session management for apis right
because the access token will expire at
some point and then you need a new
access token right I mean that's just
the way it works
um so you know
um
replacement technology for that which I
want to talk about next
um
so
in absence of refresh tokens the over
the openly connect people invented a
couple of workarounds again for being
able to get new access tokens based on
the session lifetime you have with the
with the um with the authorization
server called Silent renew and I'll show
you that in a second
um and another thing that is a concern
for a business application is if the
session ends on the authorization server
or on the openly connect provider or if
the user logs out somewhere how do you
send log out messages to your client
applications right which is in
JavaScript a little bit a little bit
more complicated because they are not
you know by definition not connected so
they came up with a couple of techniques
that I want to show you here
um
so I'm not sure about it is not working
but you see here
um
so the first the first problem let's say
is how how do we send
um well no the first problem is how how
do we get new tokens okay so you see
there's there's this renew token button
here and the idea is that the
application monitors the token Lifetime
and when the token lifetime comes to an
end it silently gets a new token okay so
[Music]
um
when I click the renew token
um button you see what's happening here
it's hard to see especially from the
back but for a for a short moment here
there's an iframe being opened to the
the authorization server back with a
special parameter called prompt equals
none which basically says don't expect
this to be inside inside of a UI flow
it's just a way to silently get a new
access token to replace the expiring
access token in my front end and the
nice property about this approach was is
that it only works as long as the user
has an existing session with the
provider right once the session ends the
iframe will be unauthenticated there
will be no token coming back
okay
um
and the other iframe you see here is a
one that points to an endpoint on the
provider called the check session
endpoint and that idea here is that you
opened an iframe in the origin of the
open open the connect provider and
inside of that
there was code running checking if the
user is still logged in on the server
okay and if the session ends on the
server it will post a message back to
the hosting application saying hey
session has ended please log out the
user in the front end okay so these were
the two session management features that
they introduced a couple of years ago
yeah so when I do this do I need classes
for that I guess I do
um when I go to the Token server here
yeah and
go here and log out
when I press the log out button you know
that iframe will detect the cookie is
gone it will fire the event and I'm it's
magic you are signed out from your
application
okay so that is um how it used to work
and you know part of the talk is is how
painful it is for developers to keep up
with all of these recommendations that
are changing all the time ma'am
now
um this JavaScript that that's kind of
like a Side Story here but the
JavaScript library that you just saw
that implemented all of this silent
renew check session and so on that that
was written by us a couple of years ago
it's called ordc client.js is is anyone
using that yeah a couple of people yeah
it's an officially certified client
Library by the open Money foundation so
you know it's it's a blessed
implementation yeah uh Brock my
colleague who was working on that he
didn't well
he was frustrated maintaining it yeah
you know JavaScript you know the whole
JavaScript landscape is changing
constantly uh you know you know people
said like okay can we open a pop-up for
login instead of doing redirect guess
what the pop-up how to open a pop-up in
a browser is not standardized across any
browser for example it works different
in Edge and whatever
um you know and you have to you know and
all of these problems actually led us to
to stop maintaining the library okay
um
on one hand it promoted in our opinion a
bad style of storing the tokens in the
browser on the other hand which I'll
show you next it is not really future
proof because browsers are changing
ma'am
um
it is pretty much well it is a done deal
that every browser will sooner or later
change the way how they deal with
cookies especially so-called third-party
cookies the other basically cookies
which are third party to the current
domain you are on yeah and the official
reason they're doing that is is to stop
uh you know tracking in the browser and
advertising and so on yeah
um
and
Safari did that already actually already
like two years ago yeah they they
started a third party blocking any
third-party cookie in in your in your
application
um Chrome wanted to do it and postponed
it because I think they were sued by the
EU because all of their websites
wouldn't work anymore
um because they're like this portal
style applications right Which pull in
iframes from all kinds of places and so
on
um but yeah people some people refer to
that as the Google Chrome cookie
apocalypse
um because uh does anyone remember when
Google introduced same-site cookies like
three years ago
break breaks right that's the
same thing that's going to happen here
again okay so you've seen these two
State management
techniques right they were both using an
iframe pointing to a third-party site
which is the openmody connect provider
and they both were relying on the fact
that in this iframe you are sending the
session cookie along right
this doesn't work anymore
okay so let me show you the same the
absolute same application that I just
run
um
this year localhost 5001
in safari
able
I need my glasses
Okay so
looks almost the same yeah so much for
browser standardization
um
when I know
and stuff will happen now yeah when I
click the login link but but to explain
what is happening is I'm now pressing
the login button I go to the Token
server come back with the tokens and
everything it's going to open the check
session iframe it's going to wait for
the server to tell them hey they are
locked out right but the iframe is oh
the iframe is opened across domain
boundaries meaning it's a third party
site from Safari's point of view it will
not send you the session cookie along
and the token server will immediately
tell the client the user is not even
logged in
okay
so when I do this
login
yeah of course the renew token thing
will not work either because it it it's
based on the same technique of sending
this session cookie across iframe
boundaries so long story short this
didn't work anymore which then LED
people to make the decision you know
what
now we're going to bring refresh tokens
to the browser right the implicit flow
didn't allow it but we're not using
implicit flow anymore right the spec
doesn't say anything about code flow so
it's allowed
right and now that this is kind of like
where Philippe's talk started right now
D is under the assumption that
browser-based applications have access
and refresh tokens right and now you're
running into all of these problems that
um we talked about in the previous talk
if they can can be exfiltrated it's bad
if they can be somehow abused to get new
ones it's bad and um you're opening up
the attack surface
considerably
okay
um
Firefox will make that change as well I
think Brave I can't remember Brave has
an option which is turned off right now
they already do it yeah have you ever
tried to open Microsoft teams with brave
they tell you use it using older browser
please
this one is too secure
yeah yeah
it's coming okay every browser will
change this Behavior which will break
every application that you build let's
say three years ago using the current
best practices
yeah
um you know some people argue that
Chrome removing cookies from the browser
is is a way to stop all of the
advertising and tracking networks
besides Googles
but that's just you know
conspiracy theories okay
um yeah so yes so we've seen we've seen
that it doesn't work anymore yeah
um
so this leaves us kind of like in a
limbo right I mean the cookie only way
we saw has the crosstalk address forgery
problems the token only way has all of
the Crosshair scripting and
stuff doesn't work anymore the way we
want it and we are forced to pull in
refresh tokens and so on
um so we have to rethink all of this I
think ma'am
um now it turns out there are some good
browser changes as well
um you know like when we go back all the
time to cross request forgery we
identified that the behavior how
browsers deal with cookies is the main
problem here right because browsers are
sending those cookies to whatever origin
they came came back in the first place
and even if I'm making cross-site
requests the browser will just take the
cookies and send the cookie across site
because they think it's where it belongs
right so actually maybe right from the
start they should have focused on
solving that problem first and that is
what happened with this thing called
same side or at least they reduced the
attack surface considerably by
introducing this thing called same side
cookies and what same side cookies means
is
um when you get a cookie from site one
it will only send that cookie back to
site one if the postback or the call
actually comes from site one okay uh and
not side two two side one which you
would have thought why isn't wasn't that
the case right from the start ma'am
um so and you know as I said when Google
introduced that feature many
applications uh were breaking yeah but
now two years later or three years later
it is pretty much deployed in every
single browser these days and the
behavior kind of is harmonized mostly I
guess
um
so this is now a real feature we can use
to build applications yeah
um
which means we should have we should
maybe rethink the whole cookie approach
before we even use tokens to solve it
okay
um at the same time we mentioned it this
morning already there is some new uh
work going on
um at the ietf about how to secure
browser-based applications this has been
a lingering issue for many many years
nobody wanted to touch it because you
know they are kind of they knew once you
start writing that spec you're going to
open Pandora's Box and you will uncover
many problems in the browser which are
unrelated to oauth and tokens which is
just you know just the way it is in
browsers yeah
um
we also mentioned this morning and I'm
totally agreeing with Philip that there
are some things which are not perfect
but
for me the most essential part of that
document is that it makes people aware
of you should think
um of your web applications in two terms
one is applications with a backend and
one is applications without a back end
right like the the pipe dream of many
JavaScript developers was I am just
going to deploy my Js and my HTML on on
a CDN that's all I need right I don't
need a web server for that I don't need
a back end right I'm just deploying my
application files and then I'm I I'm a
standalone application right of course
if you are doing this then you have to
do your overall in the browser you have
to do your open body connect the browser
you have to store your talk deposit
because there is nothing else that could
help you with that right
um so the more secure approach they are
actually
um recommending is applications with a
backend meaning you have your
browser-based application doing the UI
you have an application server that is
doing all of the security stuff like
overflows tokens token storage token
management and you have your backend
resources that you access why are and
that's that's the thing that Frozen if
you love why are the application servers
so the the JavaScript does not make API
calls anymore directly to the apis it is
using the application server who has the
tokens and manages the tokens to to
basically forward these calls
right and that is
now what we call or what what many
people in the security space call a
backend for front-end architecture
yeah
so in other words I guess uh the the
classic server side model was like this
everything was happening on the
application server right uh these are
the the fundamental building blocks you
have your authentication oauth Library
you have session management you have
token management and you have your UI
okay now the spa era flipped this all
around
and basically made everyone the browser
yeah and the model we are proposing with
the BFF is this watch this nice
animation
okay
um we are separating the concerns yeah
in the browser you have the UI framework
right doing all of the flashy stuff
um and then all of the security stuff is
going to the application server
ma'am okay
so how does it work
so I am an asp.net core guy right so
that's what I did and what I built
um and the good news is uh 80 of the
building blocks are already part of the
product so many of that stuff is already
in 180 core itself so
um for openly connect and oauth we have
the openly connect authentication
Handler in in a Sprint corpage which is
really good which is the best openly
connect client I've ever used honestly
yeah it covers all of your requirements
uh the flows Pixi code flow
everything okay so that's a proven
server-side component which is by
lengths better than anything I've seen
for JavaScript yeah
um session management right cookies yeah
first class citizen in eighth minute
core token management not so much that
there's a library I wrote I will show
you that later
um and then API endpoints I will show
you how how to do that and then
ultimately you have your static assets
to serve your HTML CSS JavaScript and so
on for the for the UI okay
so full disclosure
um I I worked on a commercial product
um called to end the BFF
um it is exactly doing what I'm showing
you
um
this is not about selling anything the
the the library is free for individuals
and companies with less than one million
dollars of Revenue if you are above that
threshold you can afford it otherwise
just keep using it
um
good so what are the building blocks if
you would like to build a BFF using
asp.net for all you need a way to serve
your static assets right JavaScript HTML
CSS
um that's where they have the so-called
static files middleware in in aspin core
you basically point to a directory on
your hard disk and then it just serves
these things as a CDN basically yeah or
a static file server
authentication and token requests using
the authentication Handler and then we
have cookies they support same-site
cookies they support all the bells and
whistles you can throw in host prefix
cookies and you know
um
other stuff and then you can also layer
on top additional ND forgery protection
which I'll show you in a second as well
yeah
I'll show that later as well yeah
yes absolutely
Okay so
this morning in the
do we expose login and log out now to
the front end if it's happening on the
server so to speak right
um and it's simple right all you have to
do on the server side is you're just
exposing two endpoints they log in and
log out and when the front end calls
these login endpoint or the logout
endpoint you are triggering your server
Side openmodyconnect Library to start
the login process or or stop it
okay and the way you're doing that is by
just plugging in the standard open ID
connect authentication Handler for
Microsoft you configure your oidc stuff
right where is my authentication server
client ID client secret interesting
point right by using that that approach
you are turning your spa which used to
be a public line into a confidential
client because now you are securely
storing a secret yeah using Code flow
query response
um and you are basically asking for the
Scopes like API access and that's
refresh tokens okay
and once there's this this has happened
right
um then the server Side Library will
issue a cookie
and
once that cookie is established in other
words you have a session you basically
another good idea would be to expose an
endpoint uh on the on the server on the
BFF so that your JavaScript front-end
can read the session information of the
user first name last name you know
favorite color whatever you want to
expose basically yeah even nicer is if
you would find a way
to do that without sliding the cookie
yeah because some some customers use
that also this is user endpoint for
check session
reasons right so you could imagine once
a minute I ping the user endpoint to see
if the user is still logged in
but that's counter productive if by
pinging the user endpoint you are
sliding the cookie into the future right
if you're using sliding expiration
cookies good news starting with.net6 you
have a way to stop sliding exploration
on a per request basis which is quite
nice
okay
so and then you plug in the cookie
Handler from Microsoft yeah
um you set your exploration your sliding
or not you set your same side by the way
using this approach you can use strict
same side note which is quite nice
because you're not you're not handling a
postback from the server anymore you can
basically use the highest same side mode
to secure your cookies that this might
not be
compatible with your application because
maybe you're having links between
applications and this is not working
with them but it's possible which was
before that not easily possible
okay let's do this let's switch to a
different demo
um
okay
so here's my BFF host
it's a standard aspin core application
um I'm adding MVC here because I have
some controllers I'll show you in a
second I'm adding some Plumbing that we
need with adbff
um
and then
essentially I'm doing exactly what I
just told you I'm adding a cookie as a
support for cookies and support for
openmody connect on the server side okay
and then the the
free endpoints I just mentioned like the
login endpoint and the logout endpoint
and the user endpoint they are basically
added here using this you know the
endpoint system in asp.core and that
gives you this free local endpoints to
to trigger the the free fundamental
session management operations okay
um
right
and when I run this
the the front end is pure JavaScript
right
um look at that a silly to do
application
um
not written by me because otherwise it
would look even worse yeah
um but basically you see here there's a
login link just like we had with our spa
before and all it does is it goes to the
login endpoint in the local application
okay
and from a user perspective it's doing
exactly the same thing as before it
shows the login page right
um
login
here we are okay
um if I would look at
the cookies
maybe this is at least working yeah so
that is a big cookie now okay
um that was another question this
morning like since now you're storing
the whole session information including
the access tokens and the claims
everything in the cookie will the cookie
get bigger yes absolutely okay and that
is kind of like what eighth minute core
does by default it just puts everything
in the cookie they have this Nifty
mechanism that they know a cookie has a
size of four kilobytes and if you're
exceeding that they're gonna open a
second cookie and the third cookie and
the fourth cookie unless you're
basically running out of cookies yeah
and they tell you oh look at that there
are two chunks here and these two
cookies are basically your session okay
this might be okay for you this might be
an issue depending on the browser and
your deployment scenario but also aspin
core by default can't just store
everything in a server-side database or
cache and just emits a cookie with a
good right and then on the way back you
just take the good go to the server side
session and rehydrate the whole thing so
there's no no difference here
um from a from a user point of view okay
and that's all as I said standard
aspirin core
same goes for the logout endpoint
right I click that I go to my to my BFF
the BFF starts to logout
and I'm I'm logged out again
okay
so log in again just to you know make
sure it works twice
um and this one here is the session
basically a way for the the client
application to get the session
information right and what this is doing
in my simple implementation it's just
basically echoing back the contents of
the cookie or the the cookies the claims
in the cookie would be the right term
yeah and you see UI is much harder than
security
um it's almost there
um but basically that's what you would
find in the cookie right these are the
claims that your application might care
about the authentication method session
ID subject ID
name you know Lookout URL when will the
session expire is another information
that you can proactively ask the server
for example and so on yeah
okay
oh yeah and actually you can create
to-do items just to prove that
yeah and the way this works
um
the to-do items is of course why an API
right so it's uh it's the next thing I
guess we have to talk about uh sorry no
first before we go to the API let me
talk about session change notifications
yeah so what if your application is
actually relying on session change
notifications from the provider so what
if you're building a business
application right and the requirement is
is if the user logs out of any of your
applications all applications should get
logged out at the same time it's called
single logout right
um
the old technique was to open this cross
side iframe right and and waiting for
notifications for that this doesn't work
anymore and for those people who did
openly connect they might know the
so-called front Channel notifications as
well which is again using iframes which
doesn't work anymore across site
boundaries yeah guess what there's a
third notification mechanism which is
called back Channel lockout
notifications and the the way this works
is basically is that
um the token server posts a Json web
token to the back end of your to the BFF
basically right to the BFF and notifies
the BFF hey the user has logged out from
somewhere either from the token server
itself or from some other application
and then the BFF knows that the logout
has occurred it can kill the session
server side right and then the next time
the front end will query the user
endpoint it will say user is locked out
that's how you would implement this in
this world yeah
again that's that's a piece we had to
add because Microsoft does not support
back Channel notifications yet
I would assume they do at some point
because you know Azure ID is by
definition always a cross-site token
service right it lives on
login.microsoftonline.com and once all
of the browsers change their cookie
Behavior every log out from Azure ID
will be broken which means they need to
implement at some point
right or
you're using our implementation
okay
good apis
yeah so um
Philip this morning said that a BFF
could be almost like a completely
generic piece of software no logic in
there just basically a thing you run
configuration file and that is
definitely one of the styles that people
use and I'll show some Styles later on
um but when we implemented BFFs with
customers we identified especially for
more simpler applications that
um they they call lots of apis
that are only called by this one front
end they are never shared between
anything else
okay so if you identify front-end
exclusive apis then you have to ask
yourself is it worth putting them into a
shared location or you should have just
put them into the BFF directly
right so in other words if you realize
I'm only I'm only calling first party
front-end same same side same origin
apis
you don't need oauth
there's no need to harm an access token
here
okay you can you can put them directly
into the back end use the cookie to
secure the communication right
and that's exactly what we're doing with
this to-do API here right so ultimately
this to do controller is just an MVC
controller
all right sitting in in the BFF itself
it is secured by the same side cookie no
oauth is needed for them
okay
nice which are shared by multiple
clients and multiple callers then you
can't use this technique and I'll show
you in a second how that would work
good
now
so I said earlier that with same-site
cookies right we now have a nice
security boundary by default if we want
to secure our local apis with cookies
only right because now we've seen that
cookies they only travel with inside
boundaries
um
now that is good and you get that by
default now
um
but by definition what same side means
is everything that's within that site is
trusted right
so if you have my company.com and you
have 500 sub domains everyone trusts
every other subdomain on that on that
company web
uh DNS name whatever you call it right
um
so if you trust you know if you're
running your banking application on one
sub domain and the marketing guys run
their CRM on this other thing do you
trust them
right so um that's one thing they have
been historically attacks where
attackers were able to take over
subdomains from companies right and now
a same-site domain runs under attacker
control well
um that's why
actually if you leave all credit goes to
you you convinced me that we need
something else than just same site
protection so we added anti-faulty
protection as well on top so that you
can secure your BFF not only
um for same site sandboxing but for same
origin sandboxing and uh it just blew my
mind by the way you know like you know
cross you know Andy fortree tokens right
in in Aspirin core they are these long
things that they generate and hash and
blah blah blah and as I learned from
Philippe you don't need all of this just
put an extra header on your HTTP call
use an uh a custom header name right and
by virtue of now requiring a cookie and
the custom header this will always
trigger course pre-flight requests if
you would make that call cross origin
yeah
huh what does it even mean
um you know course allows by but you
know the reason why cores exists is to
allow cross origin Ajax calls right and
course has two modes yeah one is if
you're doing a simple request as they
call it a get request for example they
make the request and expect on the way
back some special headers saying like
this was okay to do
okay but if you're doing a complex
request which I think yeah means for
example with credentials and a custom
header then they're doing a so-called
pre-flight request where they first
asked the API I'm going to make this
this request now it is okay and if the
API doesn't respond with the right data
they what the browser won't do it
okay now going back to Specter attacks
where I said like maybe you're able to
read the RAM on the on the browser it's
actually good to do pre-flight and not
even have the data in the first place
right so it's a little bit you know kind
of nice
anyways so it turns out by just adding a
static custom header to your HX calls
um
and enforcing them on the server side
you are automatically getting uh single
origin
like a same origin sandbox
okay
so that's what we do
um you know and with all of these
Frameworks you can just write some
Handler that automatically adds that
header on outgoing calls and if you want
to see it on the server side
here that's the middleware that we call
BFF the BFF middleware and what this
enforces is that when you're making an
API call to an endpoint that is marked
as a BFF endpoint it ensures or enforces
that this static XC surf header is
present otherwise it will reject the
call
okay
cool
so that's local apis
yeah
this only works if you don't have a
course policy that actually allows other
Origins so if you can combine this with
the course policies just like yeah
whatever we accept anything from
anywhere then sure
yes um so yes you're very right thank
you
um and by Def in this model here we
assume that the front end and the
back-end application are the same
application so there is no course right
yes
um I'll show you later some deployment
models that other people like to do
where your course is required and then
you start having to be careful about
what you open up ma'am yes
good
uh
uh yeah okay so local apis are easy what
if you don't want to do that yeah what
if you want to keep your BFF as generic
as possible and don't want to do
business logic in there or you want to
call apis which are shared by other
um
clients for example right
and ultimately the answer is reverse
proxy
okay so you somehow need to proxy them
from the BFF to the ultimate location
and why do we need to do that basically
you secure the the connection between
the front end and the BFF using the
cookie and the uh and default tree
header and then on the server side we
store the access token and then the
reverse proxy will take the access token
and call that remote API on behalf of
the currently locked on user
okay now you know many ways how to do
that
um you could run a real reverse proxy we
have customers doing this with you know
kubernetes increased controllers and all
kinds of things
um what I really like is um a package
from Microsoft called Yap which is
probably the so let's say it's easy to
Google yeah
it's going to be your first hit but it's
a really stupid name it's it stands for
yet another reverse proxy
okay anyways
um but the nice thing about Yap is it's
basically it is a reverse proxy
middleware so you can put that reverse
proxy into your application and
basically say something like if a call
comes in on slash API forward this to
server 5 API and you don't have to run a
separate reverse proxy a server or
product you know like like an ID
proofing it is actually part of your BFF
host
okay
um so
in other words if we want to enable
remote apis
you can basically just do something like
this
in your pipeline on the BFF
basically say Hey whenever a call comes
in on slash to do is the actual API
server is living here oh and by the way
while forwarding that API call attach
the access token of the currently locked
on user
okay
so basically by by doing this and
and then just you know to prove my point
I'm gonna
uncomment our local API
and now I'm going to run the to-do API
on a separate host okay and this
separate host is now just a normal API
right oops
um that is doing JWT
right that's just a standalone API that
expects the token from the token server
and it doesn't make any assumptions who
is calling it so let's run this back-end
host
right
around the front-end host
and we are now
log out and log in
see my to-do API is still working but
now it's living on a different API
server
and it's completely transparent to the
front-end application and you can move
your API at any point in time let's say
it started out as an exclusive API now
you want to share it or the other way
around you just add this reverse proxy
route and your application doesn't need
to change and there are no tokens in the
front end
yeah
okay so we are
almost done
so yeah so that's that oh yeah and by
the way I I should mention the way we
implemented this forwarding thing is is
it now does
um the cookie check first right if
you're actually allowed to access that
proxied endpoint it does the
anti-forgery check and then it only does
that if there is actually a token for
the user available so yeah so basically
it hides all of that endpoints behind
multiple additional Security checks
ma'am
token management mode
yes so
um
one feature I am missing from
Microsoft's old money connect Plumbing
is token management so they they did a
great job of getting the initial access
token and getting the initial refresh
token but that's where they stop okay
and I think uh I told them like at least
five years ago that this is missing and
every single application that does oauth
needs to do refresh token handling and
why isn't that built into their own
libraries and
it didn't happen long story short okay
so I wrote a library for that it's here
it's free uh you know apache2
um and you can just block that into a
spinet core and it does exactly that it
it keeps track of access token lifetimes
once the X tokens is about to expire it
will use the refresh token get a new
access token and basically make sure
that your application always has a valid
access token to call you
to call your apis man
I can't download it now because they're
running out of time
um
yes
so the last thing I want to talk about
here is um the various BFF Styles now
yeah so when you present this
architecture to customers or whoever you
will get mixed reactions you know some
people don't like the reverse proxy part
some people think it's too much
complexity to build a BFF
and we had this discussion already in
the morning right but it is the only way
to implement a spa and keeping the
tokens out of the browser full stop
Okay so
the probably the most simplistic way to
deploy a BFF would be you have a you
know you have your domain here where the
application comes from here's your BFF
host with the plumbing with your
endpoints with your UI assets and you
reverse proxy to your API endpoints if
need be right that's exactly what I
showed you in this simple demo now that
works fine I think for smaller
applications for smaller application
teams that own all the bits and pieces
that own the front end on the back end
they use the same programming
Technologies I guess yeah like the same
IDE maybe and things like that
um so in other words if you're a net
shop
okay then this is perfect right um
once the teams get bigger maybe they
want to use different
Technologies and so on then be very very
often see now basically a split host
architecture yeah and one flavor of a
split host architecture would be this
where basically your UI comes from one
URL which could be a CDN and the BFF
lives on a different domain or a
different uh typically a different
subdomain you know that you get the same
side thing
um
and now of course the the
consequence of that is as you rightly
say now you need course
right because now your UI your
JavaScript the caller now tries to cross
origin call Api endpoints and now you
have to open up the origin in this case
app.company.com to the back end and now
now you have to be careful of course
right because we have nd40 protection if
you open it up too much like allow all
headers or whatever yeah or allow all
Origins you know people do stuff like
that
um then of course the nd40 protection is
is gone
yeah but it's totally viable to do it
like this but you do need to
understand how course Works to to create
the right course um policy another
architecture I've recently seen that
gets around that problem looks like this
[Music]
yeah basically using two reverse proxies
yeah where basically the application
comes from here and now
um actually the front end comes from
here the BFF comes from here but from a
browser point of view they all look like
the same backend because there's a
reverse proxy proxying in both
directions basically
that gets you around the course problem
but now you have two reverse proxies and
some people say like yeah come on look
at the web there are 15 reverse proxies
already on the way to the application
host so what's what's one more
right yeah it's up to you right
um and the very last pattern I want to
show you which we touched upon very
briefly this morning is what the ITF
calls
the token mediating BFF
now that looks weird because now the
front end starts calling apis again
directly so
they have a section in their spec that
says if you can't go full BFF
for whatever reason and by the way full
BFF is the more secure version of this
that that's what they literally say is
then you could go like as Philip called
it half off bff or
partial BFF Maybe
the idea is that all of the token
handling still happens on the back end
refresh tokens flows and so on and then
you are exposing a token endpoint to the
front end where the front end can get an
access token but no refresh token and
then call the apis directly now these
access tokens would typically be very
short-lived right so that you are
minimizing the risk of token
exfiltration or you know the
effectiveness at least
um
but of course this only goes halfway
right
um while this removes some of the
concerns it does not remove the concern
of we don't want tokens in the browser
right
um
Some Cloud vendors say this is the
better approach for scalability
I don't know I'm I'm not a cloud vendor
um I don't know
um but you know there is some trade-off
somewhere right it is definitely not as
easy as just doing everything in the
browser you need to have some Trader
somewhere full BFF
split host single host TMI they all have
their little pros and cons I personally
would not do this if I'm not forced to
do it I I would rather go for the full
BFF style approach but just to make you
aware that this also exists
great
right on time
yourself it's it's obvious yeah web
security is hard
okay that's the summary here
um
and I I am 100 with Philippe saying you
cannot for security reasons draw drive
over and openly connect from JavaScript
it's it's it's it's a problem okay and
the BFF is the solution to that at least
from my point of view and now you can
ask me anything thank you
[Applause]
before we get kicked out yeah
so yeah good news yeah fully supports
websockets and hp2 and all the bells
grpc and all the bells and whistles
which is quite nice
no
so that the question is does PFF implies
sticky sessions and I think the answer
is no you can have a cluster of BFF and
endpoints right which uh which share the
same cookie
signature keys and everything and you
can do the same failover techniques as
as with any other architecture
yeah I mean the tokens could be stored
in the cookie itself or the cookie is
just near a marker for the session and
the actual tokens are stored server side
but BFF does not imply stickiness no
get it out anyway
yep
last question here
incremental consent
you mean that spec that got canceled
five years ago
[Laughter]
that you need to go back to the Token
server somehow signal that you need more
consent they will take care of the UI
and then send you back tokens I I mean
there's nothing special for the BFF it
is complicated either way you're using
it
okay cool thanks bye bye
[Applause]